bank in central london is one of the
uk's financial epicenters
but it's not just inside the buildings
that money is made these cameras may
look inconspicuous but they enabled the
city of london to issue 15.2 million
pounds worth in penalty charges between
2019 and 2021 its 3.2 million pound haul
in 2021 was about 40 percent of all such
fines levied in the city square mile and
makes it one of the most lucrative
traffic spots in the uk capital
with multiple streets converging on a
statue of the duke of wellington the
junction was once one of london's most
popular thoroughfares now the streets
feature warnings that only buses and
pedal cyclists are allowed to cross bank
junction traffic funds have become a
major generator of income across london
newham for example made 11.8 million
pounds from junctions similar to the one
at bank last year while enfield
collected 7.58 million a spokesperson
for newham said traffic restrictions cut
nitrogen dioxide in the immediate area
by 40
and the representative from enfield said
much of the money funded free travel
passes for the young and elderly
at bank junction though the traffic
rules behind its seven-figure income may
soon come to an end the city of london
is reviewing the restrictions at the
crossroads and may see them east